[Music]
as this is the first meeting this year
on the impacts of Russia's full-scale
invasion of Ukraine we must not lose
sight of the fact that the UN Charter
gives this Council the primary
responsibility for maintaining
International Peace and
security because the council is
entrusted with this responsibility we
must call out violations of
international
law last August the United States along
with Japan the Republic of Korea France
and the United Kingdom warned that arms
negotiations between Russia and the dprk
were actively
advancing we noted how the Russian
defense minister Stood Beside Kim
Jong-un at a military parade that
showcased dprk ballistic missile
advancements that were prohibited by
this
Council Russia and the dprk did what
they always do when confronted with the
truth
deflect the United States has shed light
on this situation and the world is
taking
notice this morning the United States
along with France Japan Malta the
Republic of Korea Slovenia Ukraine and
the United Kingdom issued a joint
statement condemning the military
cooperation that has now come to
fruition between the dprk and
Russia it's abhorent that a permanent
member of the UN Security Council is
flagrantly violating Council resolutions
to attack another UN member State
violations that further the suffering of
the Ukrainian people support Russia's
brutal war and undermine the global
nonproliferation
regime and yesterday secretary blinkin
along with 48 other foreign ministers
and the EU High representative condemned
the dprk's export and Russia's
procurement of dprk ballistic missiles
as well as Russia's recent use of these
missiles against
Ukraine by exporting missiles to Russia
the dprk used Ukraine as a test site of
its nuclear capable missiles in want and
disregard of Ukraine's territorial
integrity and safety of the Ukrainian
people and as these launches provide
valuable Technical and Military insights
to the dprk it can be further encouraged
to export ballistic missiles to other
countries and rake in
new Revenue to further Finance its
illegal nuclear and ballistic missile
programs
for
joh